good morning father's including my
brother John this Sunday is Father's Day
it's a cultural tradition to honor
father's and I am going to give you all
the Father's Day present a list of tips
and tricks to make your lives a little
easier here's some duct tape we all love
duct tape it's it's very manly substance
this is kind of the only size it comes
in right so if you want a smaller piece
of duct tape you have to get it off and
then you have to rip down the side
interestingly you can actually do this
permanently and you can do it any size
at all you need is an exacto knife and
the ability to not cut your face off all
using duct tape has little strings
inside of it you can see the little
ridges where those strings are cut in
between those little strings you can
actually have one duct tape that is in
effect devoted to several different
widths of duct tape so just by cutting
and yanking we now have duct tape roll
that has three different widths of duct
tape so you don't have to use the whole
thing this will make your duct tape last
much longer now let's talk about knot
knots are extremely useful the one that
we usually use is this one but it's not
very good because it binds up uh and
it's hard to undo which is why you
should always do the figure eight knot
great knot you go around and then back
up and through and this is your figure
eight now that well tighten but it's
also really easy to untie and it's done
so all I'm doing is going around it over
and then back up I can do it in a loop
go up and then over and around it up
with the loop and then you've got
yourself a figure 8 loop and this won't
go anywhere but it's really easy to
untie so if you ever need to well
fatherhood's hard but not that hard and
if you want to tie two strings together
or two USB cables with the figure eight
knot just do your figure eight knot
loosely with one of them then with the
other cut in the opposite direction and
follow this knot around gonna do and
then you have a really good knot that's
really easy to untie tip number three
flossing sucks gotta wrap it around your
fingers you gotta put your big old
fatherly hands all up in your mouth ah
all the time you've done your fingers
are turning purple and they're about to
fall off this is why you should get one
of these they are inexpensive and they
let you floss a lot home finger in your
mouth number four do you have a bunch of
old VHS tapes and family photos line
they're just taking up space and you
want to have them in a more manageable
format there are tons of companies on
the internet that will take your things
scan them so that you can have them in
DVDs or on your computer it's super easy
not very expensive and I've linked to
some of them in the description below
both of erasers are great but I hate it
when they start getting dull and amla I
can do it one more week as it yours
every her individually out of my face it
turns out that this doesn't need to be
sharpened what it needs to be is honed
it's not because the razor is dull that
it's hurting you so much it's because
there's tiny microscopic bends and
imperfections that have formed in the
razor and it's really easy to hone a
razor take out your jeans and rub it
backwards on you jeans 10 or 20 times
and all those microscopic imperfections
will totally be gone this will be much
shinier and much prettier and hurt way
less this can make expensive disposable
razors last for months instead of weeks
and now for my final trick I'm going to
teach you how to relax more eliminate
pee spatter decrease marital strife and
decrease the volume of the noise of your
urination yo-yo oh yeah that's right I
just peed sitting down I know what
you're thinking you're like what kind of
man is this see what kind of man I am
I'm a man who's comfortable with my
sexuality and I'm a man who isn't overly
concerned with the rational
constructions of our society and culture
happy Father's Day to all the fathers
and if you were a father who's only
watching this because someone sent you
that for the tips stop watching now
because it's about to get confusing I'm
playing a couple of shows in Missoula
this week in next week July 23rd is the
first the Unitarian Universalist Church
with the whomping willows and several
other wizard rock bands that are
Missoula nerdfighters come out to those
shows because I would really like to see
how many of you there are gone stop
trolling tell us what the freaking title
of your book is jeez I'll see you on
Monday